[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui on est sur le parc eiffel
paris saclay qui est un parc d'activités
mixtes entre bureaux et activités et qui
appartient la société de la tour eiffel
depuis de nombreuses années la société
la tour eiffel est une foncière de
bureaux cotée en bourse qui a comme
actionnaire majorité un groupe
d'assurances qui la hait ses mains et
qui travaille sur les territoires de
manière profonde et long terme c'est à
dire que quand on est sur un territoire
on va y rester pendant 35 ans temps sans
problème donc aujourd'hui en fait un
événement très particulier qu'est la
pose de la première pierre d'un chantier
très important pour nous qui est un
ensemble de deux bâtiments qui fait en
tout treize mille mètres carrés de
bureaux
ces treize mille mètres carrés de
bureaux dont on pose la première pierre
sont entièrement loués en l'état futur
d'achèvement à deux locataires
principaux la communauté de
l'agglomération la cps et ibm pour
installer son centre de recherche en
intelligence artificielle
on s'est dit qu'il y avait quelque chose
de très intéressant et qui est assez
rare en immobilier c'est à la fois un
tissu local de petites entreprises qui
peuvent être intéressés de se loger pour
un loyer plutôt compétitifs et à la fois
du fait évidemment du grand projet de
cluster porté par l'état et les
collectivités ici des sociétés d'ordre
national beaucoup plus
j'illustre est clairement avec des
loyers un petit peu plus faire aussi et
cette je dirais cette double population
de locataires elle est très importante
pour nous parce que nous permet de faire
plaisir en fin de de loger à la fois des
entreprises de plaies de petites et
moyennes entreprises
et puis évidemment des grands leaders
nationaux l'achèvement de ce bâti de ses
bâtiments il va avoir lieu autour de
l'été prochain en 2020 donc on a des
idées de d'extension du parc on va
évidemment travailler main dans la main
avec l'établissement public s'est déjà
des choses qui se font aujourd'hui avec
les collectivités locales
parce qu'on est très respectueux des
trame urbaine de la volonté de mixité de
la capacité à offrir aussi des services
et pour les collaborateurs des
entreprises qu'on loge ici mais aussi
pourquoi pas pour les habitants du
quartier de manière plus large
notre volonté aussi c'est en tant que
foncière de long terme apporter être
contributeurs d'un volet économique qui
est gardé les start up qui sont un cube
et dans les universités les grandes
écoles du plateau de saclay et leur
proposer de pouvoir rester sur le
plateau parce que forcément elle s'y
plaisent mais les aurait peut-être la
tentation en manque d'offre locative de
partir ailleurs en france pour nous
c'est un enjeu aussi de
responsabilisation de la foncière que
nous sommes que d'apporter des solutions
de conservation de ces startups sur le
territoire
[Musique]